how many of you guys are getting the
apple
watch yeah it just went on sale today
and all over san francisco developers
are sitting around thinking about
how do we send them more messages
on another device and get them back into
our apps
and that's fantastic for them
but every one of these little alerts and
messages is another distraction away
from our personal mission our vision our
goal
and if we're coming to conferences like
this and taking notes the way i've seen
so many people do
or reading books and really absorbing
everything and making those connections
that we need and we're still not
building
a business that's as big as we want it
to be and we're still not making the
kind of progress we want to make
i'm here to tell you that the problem is
the distractions that we have in our
lives
all those distractions that are taking
us away from our mission and my goal
here today
isn't just to tell you how to get
through that isn't just to give you a
superpower
but to get you to use it right here in
the room in the next nine and a half
minutes that sam gave me right here
we're going to do it and use it
and i know the problem
because i felt the problem i lived the
problem
a few years ago
after having interviewed hundreds of the
best entrepreneurs on the planet i sat
down and i had to admit to myself that i
was failing i was a failure i thought
and i said why all i'm trying to do
is since i've done all these interviews
with entrepreneurs
i want to start selling some interviews
and or more importantly courses with
them to my audience they're telling me
my audience is i should start selling to
them
but why am i not even able to
implement the plug-in on wordpress to
get started
right you know the problem right they're
so easy but sometimes they don't work
or worse than that why am i not starting
to actually make some sales to people
before i even get a plug-in why am i
holding back what's the problem
and when i finally got real with myself
what i realized is
that i had some a problem and many
problems that some of you guys might
identify with
i was sitting down and then email called
me away and i had to go and they'll
email you know what i'm talking about or
my im would go off or my cell phone
would buzz all these distractions taking
us away from our mission
but i had worse distractions than that
those are external distractions tell me
if you can identify with this
i had internal distractions that were
way worse
because i would sit down and you know
how sam told you that i had a business
that did over 30 million in sales
i thought well this next thing even if i
install a simple plug-in it's not going
to do 30 million after install the
plug-in maybe guys like sam are going to
see it and they're going to think
andrew's really gone down
right he took a big step down
so that was in my head i also thought
well people pay to go to conferences
but no one pays for content online
by the way that's a lie of course they
do linda one of my first interviewees
sold their company lynda.com for 1.5
billion right people pay for content she
was able to generate revenue but that's
a lie that was distracting me
and then i thought well you know what my
friend
has millions of dollars in sales he has
thousands of people who are members of a
site paying them every single month
i can't compete with that i can't do
that
by the way another lie it's not
something i wanted to do from day one i
just wanted to prove that people wanted
to buy my stuff i just wanted to prove
that i was doing quality work that
people cared enough about to buy it i
just wanted to get started i didn't need
to build a multi-million dollar company
right away
but all those thoughts all those lies
were distractions and that's what kept
me from producing that's what kept me
from using these simple plug-ins kept me
from selling kept me from doing what i
wanted to do and use all the knowledge
that i worked so hard to get and the
experience too
so i finally said to myself if my head
is just focused on all those freaking
lies and that's what's keeping me from
moving
where is the truth
what's the truth that i should be
focused on
and the truth was i didn't need
thousands of members right away i just
needed 200 members 200 people to say
andrew i like your work enough to pay
you for it andrew i'm gonna be here a
member of your community for the next
few months all i need is 200.
and the truth was that my customers my
audience was telling me charge us we
they wanted to support us but i wasn't
listening
right
the problem was i had all these truths
that i wanted how big i wanted to build
my business and instead of focused on
them being focused on them and going
towards my mission
i kept getting distracted by email and
getting distracted by the junk in my
head
so i finally just sat down and i said
what is true for me and it's what's true
is i want to build a legacy business and
only ideas will do it the way that i
want it not software and people will pay
for it if i do a good job with it the
truth is i wanted 200 members the truth
is my audience loves my work i want to
do more
and so i picked one of those
and i said i'm going to focus on one
200.
and instead of walking into into work
every day thinking how someone else was
doing better i would walk in thinking
200. in fact you guys see i'm wearing
some of these beads i'll explain them in
a moment i just walk in i use these all
over the world people have them so when
i was on a trip somewhere i bought a set
and i started to use them i would say
200 and i'd move that big fat bead right
there the one with the knot and then i'd
say 200 yeah i could do 200
then i move the next one go 200 if i get
200 i could get started and i could
start really paying money for
advertising 200 yeah
right and i just say 200 200 200.
and within a few weeks first of all i
started actually implement what i needed
to do i installed the plug-in but i got
200 members
and they were all paying month after
month after month and they loved the
work and then soon after that i got over
200 new members every single month and
things started to really take off and
today there's a whole organization there
at mixergy that helps me do my
interviews and create my courses and
there's a community of people who are
there who are members to listen to it
because i focus not on the junky email
but on the mission and what i wanted and
what i knew was possible 200.
do you ever find yourself getting
distracted from your mission i want to
show you how to get back into it
there's something called in cognitive
psychology called target fixation
i never understood it until my brother
took motorcycle safety lessons when he
got his bike he said look watch these
videos they gave us in class everyone's
going to crash
i said michael you're getting a bike why
do you need to know this
and he said look at that and sure enough
just before the crash all of them did
these two things you could almost see
that their attention was going over
towards the wall and you could almost
see them saying don't hit the wall and
then they would ride and
hit the wall
right
um it was target fixation you whatever
you fixate on whatever target you fixate
on is what you're gonna hit and so when
i was fixated on the target of email and
when i was fixated on the target of my
my friend doing better i was hidden
walls but once i decided i was going to
fixate on my own target things started
to actually happen towards it
so
that's me
my goal here isn't to tell you my story
and to have you guys just hear and learn
what works for me i want you guys to try
it with me and so
we
i went to a factory in china i called
them up and i got
500 beads just like this to pass out and
the team here is going to be handing
them out right now
i want to make sure all of you guys get
it we're going to try the exercise right
here together
and i want you to have something that
you can take with you when you go home
because i've gone to conferences learned
something good
written it down said i promise i'm going
to use it and i never used it
and while they're passing it out i'd
love to get a couple of people up here
to help out corey do you want you guys
want to help do you want to come up here
the idea is this
we're going to have our word just like
mine was 200. we're all going to share
the same word and then we're going to
start with this big do you guys see that
big fat bead it's called the guru bead
the one that has a not on it we're going
to start by putting our thumb and index
finger on that
and we're going to touch it and move it
and then we're going to use our index
finger to touch the next one and the
next one until we touch every single one
of them and this holds you accountable
it's so easy to say ah you know what i
got it and do it one time and then get
sucked right back into your rut which is
oh i've got to answer email i've got to
do this other thing no we're going to
focus on what we want not what other
people are telling us to focus on not on
those distracting lies in our in our
minds i call it true mind because i'm
going to find something that's true
useful and wanted to focus on it looks
like everyone's got it right
all right let's try together
for a focus exercise i'd love for us
instead of using 200 that was mine i
want us to use one word like a mantra
together here so put your thumb and
index finger on that guru bead that fat
one with the knot let's hold it up or
somewhere that you can see it
and
actually what we're going to do is put
it on your thumb and we're all going to
hold with the index finger we're going
to tap down that big one and we're going
gonna use and we're gonna say the word
focus together ready
one two three focus
yeah now let's move over to the next one
this is reminding us to focus
one two three focus yeah
next one one two three focus
let's say it louder let's make sure that
sam who's in the back there probably
worried about what his next speaker is
and if we're all on target let's make
sure he even hears it
go to the next one one two three focus
yeah sam
he can hear us he's saying good
now let's try it now internally i wasn't
walking around on the subway on my way
to work on 200 200 200 right
i just mentally going in saying yeah i
could do 200 i'll do it so why don't we
try it all together
but privately quietly try to do a full
round and as you say it remember to
bring back your focus
focus is so important there's there's a
story about how warren buffett and bill
gates met at dinner for the first time
and bill gates mom was there and she
asked everyone around the table what's
the most if you could sum up what got
you here in one word what what word
would you use to sum it up and warren
buffett and bill gates both use the same
word which was focus they're just so
focused right and we're gonna get back
into focus here together so why don't we
start with the guru beat and we'll do it
again just mentally think of the word
you know what actually let's stand up
and do it we shouldn't have to sit down
the whole time let's stand up you could
keep it anywhere by you
how do you guys feel about it
good
jack you're a product guy is this clear
enough am i doing a good job explaining
how to do it
all right
right you guys all see him on product
hunt with with one eye out and a tongue
out yeah that's the look
all right so let's try it let's start
with the first one
just think focus to yourself as you move
that first one
then go to the next one we're gonna
touch each one of these make sure to
keep thinking about focus
if your mind starts to wander don't
worry about it because your fingers are
going to move over the next beat and
your mind will remember hey i've got to
bring it back to what i'm doing here the
word focus and move the next speed
and hold yourself the way you would when
you're really focused
so you want to feel it as you're saying
the word as you're thinking the word
feel focused and reconnect
and when you've got them all just grab a
seat
so focus is a good word to keep coming
back to and i wanted one that we'd all
have together
but as you're trying this yourselves now
that you've got this come up with a word
or a really short phrase that has more
significance to you personally that's
much more connected with your personal
mission that's much more about what you
want to do and use that word and as
you're walking around and you're tempted
to just check your phone for one more
time i love it or check your apple watch
which mine is coming in a few days i'm
got nothing against it
but spend some time just bringing
yourself back to what you want to your
own personal mission everyone else is
going to get you distracted
this these true mind beads are going to
bring you back to what's true for you i
could do 200 what could you do i truly
wanted to do 200 what could you what do
you truly want to do keep bringing back
to that
all right thank you guys for all trying
for trying it i'd love to hear how this
all works out for you i'm going to be
here to say hello and let's give them a
big round of applause for jumping up
here thank you
cool